good morning thank you for joining us
let's talk about nasgany to start with
um how offended are you on behalf of
your colleague given what she says she's
been through
well nozzle's a valued colleague i've
known her for a very long time
she's worked incredibly hard both as a
minister and as a backbencher she's made
a very serious allegation it was
the prime minister spoke to her last
night and said that the cabinet office
will investigate this and look at the
detail of this
she put out a statement last night
saying actually
and to be fair to that you know this
could be people who weren't even members
of the conservative party which is why
we have to get the bottom of this very
quickly
and of course the chief whip has come
out and named himself as the individual
and now i work with both colleagues and
i think it's important
that um you know someone like
a cabinet office senior civil servant
should look at this properly because
chief was also categorically denied this
i think it's important that well i'm not
going to impugn either colleague you
know we're we're one team we work well
together
as a team and that's what the nation's
expects and this is a this is of course
and as i say this is a serious
uh allegation it you know it takes
someone a lot to
make such a
a a claim i think it's a point that um
has allowed
the ability to put her
case forward put the evidence forward to
the cabinet office
why didn't anybody take what she had to
say seriously at the time i don't think
uh that's true i think that's what she
feels the the important thing is that um
well she's also said that that
you know she
spoke to the prime minister prime
minister wrote her asked her to
put forward a a formal complaint she
didn't think that was the correct
procedure now the cabinet office can
look at this
properly
and i hope um be able to report back
swiftly when something like this happens
it's the job of the chief whip to put
their arms around an mp and protect them
while there is an inquiry going on
whatever given that this allegation is
by all intents and purposes he's out
here himself against the chief whip what
did the prime minister offer her instead
to protect her during that time well i
think what the premise has done and he
spoke to nuscanni
last night is to offer her that
investigation from the cabinet office
which i think when you read her
statement
well he offered her
two years ago
at the time
for her to make a formal complaint
and use the party procedure
uh i think she also went before the
um islamophobia inquiry that professor
singh held for the party
um but look these are really
painful allegations um for anyone um of
luz's background
uh uh to make i think it's important
that she gets
uh to be able to put her evidence
forward to understand why it's a party
issue i mean if if somebody actually
said that to her um it's islamophobic
well as i said
she needs to now be able to put her
evidence uh forward and i think the
right thing to do is to allow the
cabinet office to invest are you saying
it's her fault no not at all it didn't
come to light two years ago not at all
not at all i think
um as i said you know
i i don't have all the details she's
made an allegation which was in the
sunday papers and then of course
followed up with the statement the
important thing
is that you know what she's asked for is
what the prime minister um has now
spoken to and is delivering through
the cabinet office inquiry i wonder why
it's taken two years to get to this
position
well as i said i think the the yeah what
happened two years she was a vulnerable
woman she went to the prime minister she
said this is what's happened to me i've
been um sacked because i'm too muslim
basically um and it's taken two years
for it to come to light well and he took
it very seriously and he said if you
absolutely well this is a prime minister
who's uh said that muslim he likened
muslim women to uh letterboxes and bank
robbers well it's also the prime
minister that has you know promoted
sahabi
anything other than uh the important
thing to remember is this is a prime
minister in in my view who doesn't you
know look at
your background your religion or
anything else he looks at you your
ability
and uh you know whether you are capable
of doing a job and then
actually makes that decision at the same
time
the prime minister muslim well again i
was going to say and it's the same it's
the prime minister who
actually asked a professor singh to
conduct an inquiry into islamophobia the
inquiry came back with some
recommendations which the party's
overhauling its systems
said about that i think the findings of
this report show clearly that the
conservative party is institutionally
racist
well it made a number of recommendations
uh for the party they also said that
that um
islamophobia was not widespread in any
way in the conservative party
i don't believe that i've been a member
of the party
i have you know with all respect
apparently has vastly anyone else i've
been a member of the party since the
late 80s
i've risen through the party i've been a
local counsellor for three terms i've
been a
volunteer
uh in the voluntary party i've been a
member of parliament i have not actually
experienced any form of
women
muslim women are saying that they they
don't feel that
the party is is uh treats women of color
particularly muslims appropriately
my my view is of course we can always do
better which is why we have the inquiry
which is why we're overhauling our
systems there is no place as i said in
my tweet over the weekend for any form
of racism of islamophobia anti-semitism
in our politics in our party i take
great pride in the work i'm doing
with the education sector at
universities in terms of signing up to
the international definition of against
anti-semitism the work we're doing at
schools the work we're doing across
government i think that's important to
remember but you know in a case where a
colleague a valued colleague um comes uh
forward and says look i i've you know
heard this or i i think you know
there are issues that i want uh aired
and dealt with it's only right that we
then deal with them what should happen
to mark spence in the meantime well i
think that mark spencer again i work
very closely with with mark has
categorically denied and said this is
defamatory so i think it's only right
it's only first one of our values you
remember when we talked about the sue
grey report before um
taking five minutes we've got to see
well
it's one of our values values of
fairness and and people have to have a
fair hearing yeah uh and i'm not going
to impugn the reputation of either
colleagues right that the cabinet
obviously looks at this okay william
let's talk about uh him and share of
these standards uh deputy chair of the
standards committee um he is seeing the
police today after allegations of
threats and blackmail
against mps
is whipping bullying
or is it bringing mps into line
so i've got good experience with this
not because i've been in the whips
office quite the country i've been a
backbencher for a very long time it's
taken me
uh 11 years to uh get to secretary of
state i am the definition of it is a
marathon not a sprint in politics and
for seven eight years i was a
backbencher i've rebelled um the whips
and i've never experienced
the sort of um stuff that uh william rag
is describing at all i can tell you and
many colleagues actually over the
weekend came out with a number of
articles saying they don't recognize
this others did though
and i think they have you know then a
responsibility to put that evidence
forward all i can say to you from my own
experience i haven't experienced any of
that and i've rebelled before but it
hasn't impacted anything to do with with
my work for my constituency all
government decisions you know there is
due process in government whether it's a
department of education or any other
department in housing you brought up the
department of education education
secretary because christian wakeford
said that he was told by the previous
education sector gavin williamson that
if he didn't come into line then they
would remove a school that was promised
in his constituency of berry
would you as education secretary have
the power to withdraw funding for a
school in an mp's constituency no
because we have due process in
government
that is absolutely not what happens
in the way we take it you don't believe
christian
christian wakeful has just crossed the
floor and joined the labor doesn't mean
he's a liar no i'm not i'm not saying
that i'm just saying to you that he's
made an allegation against a colleague
gavin williamson um uh
clearly does doesn't have allegations
against a lot doesn't exist well no but
all i'm saying to you is is christian
wakefield has chosen to leave the
conservative party and join the labour
party um all i would would
share with your viewers is that the way
we conduct ourselves
as a department of education we have due
process which we follow that particular
school is getting the funding that that
that it needs nothing has changed so you
know there is an inconsistency here um
in terms of what christian wakeford is
saying and what the reality is on the
ground okay um
talk to me about while we're on schools
are you pledging 9 000 air cleaning
units we are so you remember when i came
on the program
a few weeks ago we delivered 350 000 co2
monitors to schools last year to monitor
uh the air in the classrooms and the
data we got back which we're publishing
our survey on this today is that
actually the bulk so 90 for 95 of uh
classrooms were able to ventilate and
keep the air fresh from the data we were
getting from our co2 monitors that was
25 million investment in co2 monitors
then we modeled as to which classrooms
we thought may not be able to do that
easily and we thought i think we're
gonna need about eight thousand air
purifiers yeah we think we need about
nine thousand now and so actually
in terms of being stewards of public
money
rather than
you know
following what the labor party wants us
to do which is buy 350 000 air purifiers
at a massive cost to the
exchequer
we bought 8 000 actually last week we
got all the um
schools uh to make their um uh
allocation and we got to just over nine
just over eight thousand so we've gone
to nine thousand now we're delivering
air purifiers uh to help those schools
it's part of making sure that education
remains open i'm passionate about making
sure children
remain in school remain in education we
see all the evidence from the children
commissioner that that's really
important and that's why we're doing
including of course making sure that
that teachers get themselves tested
twice a week uh and of course the
vaccination program which we just spoke
about okay and what is your advice to uh
school heads um who still want their
kids to wear masks even though it's not
compulsory anymore
so we we we trust school heads and
school leaders to do the right thing i
think they would agree that masks can be
a challenge for learning for
communication in the classroom which is
why i wanted them not to last a day
longer than necessary when we saw the
data
from the scientists that omicron was
plateauing and actually numbers were
beginning to drop and they told us that
we've reached the peak i moved very
quickly to say the guidance to where
mastering the carson can come away last
week the guidance for wearing masks will
fall away as part of plan b this week
um that's i think the the right thing to
do and of course
i speak to directors of public health
have done a tremendous job working with
school heads to make sure that we get
this right in localities if there is a
an outbreak in a locality they can
reintroduce temporarily uh masks in
communal areas if they wanted to but
they work very closely with us and it's
a you know it's a strong relationship i
have with the front line i'm very proud
of that yeah i didn't ask about downing
street parties once but i will be asking
later on in the week uh what does tl
stand for tory leader
t levels i'm going to make them as
famous as a-levels these are technical
they're a fusion between an
apprenticeship and an a-level and
actually there are fantastic things
which you're going to hear much more
about from me looking forward to it
thank you very much indeed thanks a lot
education secretary thank you